now we turn overseas to the African
country of Sudan where thousands of
Americans and other foreigners are still
hoping to escape Fierce fighting that
has killed hundreds of people they're
trying to get out of the country during
a shaky 72-hour cease-fire that took
effect overnight in TS Taya reports on
the dangerous situation
the latest Saudi and U.S brokered
ceasefire looks much like this failed
attempt before it making it clear
Sudan's boring generals have no
intention of laying down arms
your constant gunfire continues to Echo
across the Sudanese capital and heavily
armed fighter jets can be seen streaking
low across the cartoon Skyline as
civilians including several thousand
foreign Nationals remain caught in the
crossfire like Amir Osman who's from
Scotland he has a bus he shows us the
bus he and his family are considering
boarding to Egypt a 13-hour journey
through dangerous terrain are you not
worried about putting your family on
this bus and driving all those many
hundreds of miles to the Border
more it well I think I'll be more
worried if I stay
for more than a week Sudan's Army Chief
General Abdul fatah al-braham has been
battling for power against his former
Ally turned bitter rival General
Mohammed hamdan de gallo the commander
of the nation's feared paramilitary
Force known as the rapid support forces
hundreds of diplomats including American
were evacuated over the weekend in
daring high-risk rescue missions but an
estimated 16 000 U.S Nationals remained
trapped as the fighting only gets worse
I don't have any plans or announcements
to make about the United States point
peacekeepers to Sudan to putting
American boots on the ground to try to
keep the peace in Sudan that is not
presently in contemplation I don't
expect it will be
now U.S citizens in Sudan have been told
the state department will provide them
with guidance on land routes out of the
country and that they'll receive
assistance to leave the region once they
reach those designated areas but that of
course is little Comfort to those unable
to embark on what would be an extremely
risky Journey all in the hopes of trying
to reach safety Nate
our thoughts are with those who attempt
to make that journey in those who remain
trapped MTS tie up thank you